hopes to make it five good to see you
uh any added excitement knowing you'll
be able to play
in the nba finals in front of the home
fans for the first time
just does it feel like it's something
starting a little bit
over again just the fact that you guys
are home i'm just here not to get fined
i'm joking i'm joking uh um
no it's gonna it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be fun you know plenty
you know nba finals game
in front of the fans that have supported
us all year long and uh it's been it's
been 50 years since we
played one here in milwaukee
for sure it's gonna be exciting eric in
the back
hey honest um for you in that game
as you get 40 as you get to 42 you hit a
number of those mid-range jumpers those
turnarounds that you've been working on
do you feel like you've had like a
breakthrough on that at all in the
postseason where like you're feeling
even more comfortable with that shot
it felt like maybe during the net series
like you got to it a couple more times
like
what what are you feeling with that shot
and kind of how you use it right now
um hopefully you know i'm more
comfortable not trying to think about it
now that you said it i might go and miss
them tomorrow because of you
but uh no i'm feeling more comfortable
you know i'm just trying to be
aggressive try to go downhill sometimes
you know guys
you know stay in front of me or you know
they create a wall that
doesn't allow me to get in the paint so
you got to try to figure out other ways
to be effective
you know either is that past the ball
either is pull up for a
minute jump shot or you know get to a
spot
bump them and then you know shoot over
them but you just gotta figure out ways
to be effective
you know you know sometimes you're gonna
make them sometimes you're gonna miss
them
but you gotta keep being aggressive and
uh but my my mindset is always
try to get downhill try to make the you
know that i play the right decision
either is that a pass either is that
scoring but
um as i said sometimes like you have to
take those shots you got to keep
keeping the you know the difference
against you know but i i feel
i feel comfortable and um
you know hopefully moving forward i can
feel more comfortable in those shots and
be even more effective jeff over here
i have to giannis um why were you
worried about getting fined
he's in um the football player was uh
marshawn lynch
marshall and lee said that in his media
day
but do i have to do this this is my
first time here i don't know what i'm
doing man this is my first time the nba
finals
i don't know if i get fined i don't know
if i really have to do this so i can
just go home you know
um but probably if i if i don't do it
they probably go
you know find me i don't know the more
serious question
when you decided to commit to the
extension
how did you tell the box who did you
call or who did you text
oh man i don't remember um
uh i don't i probably um talk with um
john horst i think um
i think uh if i'm not i'm not i think i
use him
called him called him and told him uh
yeah you know you know i'm staying
[Music]
and then just hang up the phone and just
went about my day
you know and um that was pretty much it